Marcus Lawrence lives for classy cars he
and some friends run a special workshop
for them and bond they often come across
old Porsche models like this 1989 24
carrera GT of which only 406 were built
Lepke Marcus says he started going to
races as a kid and he began to take the
wheel himself as soon as he was old
enough he was allowed to race a porsche
924 carrera GT and helped his team to
victory now he is looking forward to
racing one again once the car is up and
ready often despite vida then de vaghy
the phonetic spellings mothball today we
are tempting Marcus with the new Porsche
Panamera Turbo it packs a lot of power
but does he think it would be a good car
for the race track in fact I thought
vines that in comparison with the old
racing cars the Panamera looks like a
spacecraft from the future but from the
front it has the typical Porsche look
it's the positive
the money need Marcus says if you look
at the central console you'll feel like
you're traveled forward in time but all
the buttons are probably for all the new
comfort and assist systems if you look
at the dashboard it still has the good
ol round Porsche instruments done I
can't run from the item want instrumenta
on an item part of either
time now to look at what the Beast has
under the hood Monica not to Marcus says
he can recognize the typical turbo
engine details in a turbo engine the air
intakes don't go to the motor head but
past the engine to the side of the turbo
setup before passing back to the engine
through the air cooler on the Union
first act yachts boat cylinder bahane
lean and calm down a street in la de
love kula here V lotsa work in an unlock
tract map he says turbo engines were
first introduced back in the 1970s also
in series models Porsche was one of the
earliest to do this racing cars and the
late 70 sometimes had a performance
similar to the new panamera turbo but
not as long lasting the engines needed
an overhaul after each race but
hopefully this one will run for a few
hundred thousand kilometers
the technical data speak for themselves
the Panamera Turbo packs an impressive
382 kilowatts or 520 horsepower making
it one of the sportiest members of the
Panamera family its prints from 0 to 100
km/h in just 4.1 seconds and has a top
speed of 305 km/h but it can also take
things easy
this is our tester says it is a great
car to drive tight steering and
surprisingly comfortable he says you can
use this high-speed car for longer trips
and in the city and Marcus really likes
that Parker says the double clutch
transmission is great fun in the past he
wouldn't have gone for automatic
transmission but this one changes up
quickly and smoothly through seven years
Marcus says that is better than the old
four or five gear systems and he loves
the gearshift paddles Marcus puts his
foot to the floor on the Autobahn on
this section there is no speed limit
the license and five Marcus is impressed
520 horsepower and 700 Newton meters
starting at 2,250 revs per minute this
car really moves he says it gets even
better when you push this sport or sport
+ buttons the whole chassis seems to
tighten up Marcus says just listen to
that roar you know it could even go
faster kanika hood when of their soul
and heart affords does that not one
missing me I get
but how would the panamera turbo size up
on the racetrack
yeah mishit i bethought marker says he's
convinced by this all-rounder he is
impressed by a sedan combining sport and
comfort but it weighs 2,000 kilos when
it's empty so it is not a race car
someone looking for something more agile
and purest should go for a classic
portion of it there's a shiny diamond
cluster from Porsche that's aberdeen